hey guys it is the 19th of februari my
name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching games fun news Sony is known
for having a pretty bad time in the
profitable company stakes and now it
seems they're gonna try and rectify it
according to Reuters Sony see you Kaz
Hirai said that the company is preparing
to ditch their efforts in the smartphone
business since it's dominated by Apple
and Samsung that would be one big
segment of their business gone but her I
also indicated that stepping away from
there once successful TV business is
also not out of the question the company
will instead plan to focus on their
camera sensors and playstation products
which it hopes will have a hypothetical
operating profit of 4.2 billion by 2018
a new rock band game could be in
development for new gen consoles
according to a report from bloomberg a
source who claims to be familiar with
harmonics as plans confirms the news but
we've heard nothing official from the
development themselves Harmonix just
recently began launching new rock band
dlc for the first time in two years and
has been talking about their plans to
revive the rock band franchise for a
good while harmonics will also have a
booth at PAX East next month for the
first time in two years and is listed
among this year's PAX East pins
curiously though their pin design only
depicts a question mark suggesting that
an announcement could be on the way
before the show there are set to be at
least three games playable at the PAX
harmonics booth including a city sleep
there Samsung gear VR project and the
kick-started amplitude reboot for ps3
and ps4 finally today the ps4 is slated
to be the new ps2 or we in terms of
console sales success research firm
strategy analytics have predicted that
the ps4 will outsell the xbox one by
forty percent by 29
pain the details come from they're
connected home devices report which
suggests only we sell 80 million units
by 2019 while Microsoft will likely sit
at 57 million and its first year of
release 18.5 million PS balls were
shipped which is close to matching the
20 point 1 million figure that the ps2
console achieved as for the Xbox one it
is estimated that only 12.4 million
units were shipped in the first year but
that's still a better performance from
the 10.4 million xbox 360's that were
shifted in that same period the ps2
remains the best-selling console of all
time with more than 150 million consoles
so while the way comes in second with
over a hundred million consoles making
their way into living rooms worldwide
let me know down in the comments if
you're keen to play a brand new rock
band you can head to gamespot where
we've got stories on Tim Schafer
defending Peter Molyneux and what's new
in the upcoming Xbox one system update
that's all I have to tell you about
today but do you remember that tomorrow
I'll have my top five stories of the
whole gaming week so if you want to get
caught up that's supposed to be